no I'm not above a cheap gag ant-man the
latest entry in Marvel yeah sorry hold
on okay that's better ant-man is the
latest entry in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it's the first one in a
while that I've been really nervous
about going in to see because I did not
think this was gonna be a great movie I
didn't think was going to be bad but a
lot of what I knew about sort of the
process of it being made what went on
behind the scenes and what I was seeing
of it it was reading mediocre to me
thankfully up I actually came away quite
pleasantly surprised a lot of it comes
down to characters and Cassie we've got
Paul Rudd as Scott Lang who is an
ex-convict who will eventually take on
the mantle of ant-man who is actually
here who's been around for a while but
has basically been in retirement now
Paul Rudd is an actor that I've never
been totally on board with I don't
dislike him but he's never struck me as
being worth sort of the the hype and the
good leading man status that he's earned
this is the first time he really works
for me because he really strikes a very
good balance of being competent in the
action scenes incredible as a hero while
having the proper level of sarcasm is
sort of self-effacement that this
character specifically really needed
because I mean you say a man and people
kind of just snicker and the best way to
defuse that is to actually intend to
make them laugh and he works very well
for that he's backed up by a really good
supporting cast as well there's the
other members of sort of his crew you
know some other ex-con characters who on
paper are fairly thin and don't have a
lot going on but all of them are
performed with enough energy and with
enough chemistry and our fun enough that
you like them when they're around in
some cases you probably wouldn't mind
seeing more of them you've got
Evangeline Lilly playing a fully formed
interesting well motivated and very
capable female character who is not just
there to be a love interest which is a
huge relief in fact a lot of where love
interest would have fit in that role is
kind of taken instead by Scott Lang's
daughter no that's not as weird as the
sentence I said makes it sound what I
mean is his whole redemptive arc which
normally would have been encapsulated
with a Roman
interest is instead encapsulated with
his relationship with his daughter so it
becomes a story of father-daughter
redemption which is mirrored with Hank
Pym and his daughter which is the
Evangeline Lilly character now Michael
Douglas's Hank Pym to me was the MVP of
this movie I loved him from start to
finish i love when we first scene which
actually starts on a flashback with the
best d aging technology I've ever seen
put to use he's able to convey
intelligence much in the same way that
Robert Downey jr. does really well with
tony stark and his age really works very
well because you get that feel like this
guy's got some real history and he's
he's probably been through some really
nifty Avengers but he's kind of done
with that at this point or he'd like to
be at any rate I really hope we get to
see more of him whether it is in
flashbacks whether it is in current it I
want to see more Hank Pym and even
though he made the character really
likable he didn't lose the darker
aspects of the character because we see
sort of flashes of his temper and we see
the aspects of his character that make
him hard to light which is important to
have that in there somewhere but they
didn't go as far with it as the comic
book softened if you read the comics
Hank Pym is it's kind of a raging jerk
to make the character fully layered
without actually having him be unlikable
the movie also does a very good job of
selling the concept of ant-man on an
action basis cuz the idea that a hero
that gets this big is going to get into
a fight and win it that's a hard sell
and the movie does a very good job of
making that work and making his power
feel like a legitimate and viable
superpower because again you think oh he
shrinks what good is that well they show
you and even when the action gets rammed
up it's balanced with the comedy really
nicely I mean especially in the
climactic fight and I'm actually
complained about that before and throw
the dark world it felt like they stopped
to the action scene or to make a joke
this time the jokes are actually very
organic to the action scene because you
know at times when you sort of pull the
camera back and get to the reality that
they're this big and fighting on a table
full of Children's Choice yeah that's
kind of funny and it becomes a natural
flow of the scene that they're able to
inject comedy and that injection of
comedy doesn't kill the tension and the
Pacey
the action scene it's not a perfect
movie though I could throw net picks out
there I won't do that but the big
problem is the villain again and that is
becoming the recurring problem with a
lot of the more recent Marvel movies in
this case we've got Darren cross and
he's functional as a villain you know
he's intimidating enough and he's a big
enough threat but as a character got the
guys just cartoonish they do some stuff
later on Dave you better insight into
sort of his personal motivations and
maybe a little bit of a logistical
explanation as to why he is the way he
is but it comes too late because really
the second scene we see him and he does
something so stupidly cartoonishly over
the top villain estate he can't take him
seriously as a character if they had
built up to that showed us the layers
first and then showed how far that all
pushed him it might have worked
ultimately the movie I'm reminded the
most of is the first iron man movie
which I do love and is one of my
favorite movies in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe however I can't quite hold this
up at the same level even though it
reminded me a lot of that and I think yo
in a vacuum they are about equal for
slightly different reasons but the thing
is is this feels like a movie that
should have come out in early and phase
one in the early parts of Marvel because
to get this kind of origin story again
and to have it sort of play out the way
that it does it just it feels like
Marvel's gotten past this kind of story
I mean we're getting things like
espionage thrillers with the winter
soldier and space opera with guardians
of the galaxy so to come back with what
is ultimately just another origin story
well done origin story don't get me
wrong it it feels slightly like a step
back it feels like a movie out of time
and it should have come out about five
years ago I mean that said it's not just
an origin story it is also a heist movie
so having that extra layer does help
ultimately I like ant-man I'm certainly
glad i saw it i can't say that i love it
certainly not as much as you know my
favorite movies in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it was worth my time which
I wasn't entirely sure it was going to
be so have you seen a man yet if he did
what did you think about it if you
haven't seen it yet what is your current
favorite movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe whatever the case is on
those questions drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it and
until next time this council is
adjourned